looking for work this is how to score a
job interview at the scp foundation
enjoy dealing with interesting people on
the job do you love the idea of every
day at work possibly being your last if
so then we may have a position for you
want to be a researcher pick an esoteric
scientific field and then rise to the
top of it before developing an obsession
with studying the supernatural you'll
get laughed out of academia and right
into an scp containment site want to be
a guard or an mtf member become a stone
cold military badass get the rest of
your team tragically killed by an
anomaly and start seeking revenge until
the foundation decides to let you go pro
want to be a member of the o5 council
see to it that one of the current
members disappears that seems to work
like a charm good luck want to be a
d-class oh that's easy just commit a
series of pretty horrific murders seek
the death penalty at your trial and say
yes if any mysterious men in white coats
offer you a way out note scp explained
absolutely does not endorse committing a
series of pretty horrific murders or any
kind of murders whatsoever we're just
talking jokes here folks and if you say
otherwise we'll deny it in court